Подарунком українцям назвав керівник "Укренерго"
угоду про умови приєднання України до європейської енергосистеми.
Її підписали в Брюсселі 28 червня.
В угоді фактично перелічені домашні завдання для України,
час на виконання - 5 років.
З огляду на складність цих вимог часу не так багато.
Україна має модернізувати свою енергосистему
і привести електростанції у відповідність до євростандартів.
Уже це - надзавдання,
якщо поглянути на актуальний стан українських ТЕС.
Ще одна вимога - реформувати та зробити прозорим
ринок електроенергії. Завдання, як бачимо, складні.
А що дасть Україні приєднання до енергосистеми Європи?
Приєднання до енергосистеми Європи - це насамперед
енергетична безпека. Європейський енергопростір
об’єднує 34 країни ЄС
і 42 оператори електромереж. Україна ж для європейської енергосистеми -
своєрідний ізольований острів.
96 відсотків енергосистеми України
сполучені з Росією, Білоруссю і Молдовою.
Це загрозлива залежність, адже у випадку дефіциту електроенергії
Росія залишається
єдиним постачальником струму в Україну.
Якщо ж Україна синхронізується в електропостачанні з Європою,
то в разі потреби
зможе імпортувати струм з ЄС.
Європейські енергетичні оператори
зможуть прийти в Україну.
З'явиться реальна конкуренція.
Тарифна політика стане прозорою і зрозумілою, а отже, виграє споживач.
Також, приєднавшись до енергопростору ЄС,
Україна теоретично зможе експортувати струм до Європи.
Нині експорт до Євросоюзу можливий
лише з Бурштинської ТЕС. Вона єдина наразі під'єднана
до енергосистеми Європи.